[Aplausos]
y cuál es la esencia de la vida pregunta
recurrente que seguramente muchos de
nosotros nos hemos planteado en algún
momento de nuestra existencia y más
frente a un mundo como este tan lleno de
contrastes tan contradictorio tan
paradójico como injusto y hermoso
a la vez hoy voy a compartir con ustedes
una experiencia que a mí me ha acercado
a conocer un poco más de la respuesta de
esta pregunta es una historia que me ha
enseñado
que la felicidad está en el servicio al
otro ahí donde la felicidad del otro se
convierte en la propia esa historia para
mí tiene un nombre y se llama música
para la vida la mía ya la ha
transformado sin duda
todo comenzó una tarde de otoño cuando
un grupo de personas de esos que creemos
que el mundo puede ser un mejor lugar
para vivir llegamos a una comunidad en
un municipio del estado de san luís
potosí
sabíamos de antemano que en ese
municipio había altos índices de
emigración de marginación de violencia
la presencia reconocida de la
delincuencia organizada los consumos a
edades muy tempranas de alcohol y de
drogas
todos ellos datos duros tan duros como
ese día los rayos del sol nos pegaban
directamente en la cara
lo primero que hicimos fue contratar un
camión de perifoneo estábamos
convencidos de que nuestro proyecto
verdaderamente iba a transformar esa
realidad así de grande entonces el
camión inundó las calles del pueblo con
el huapango de moncayo como fondo
musical y una voz que decía atención
niños niñas y jóvenes si tienes entre 7
y 17 años te gusta la música y quisieras
formar parte de una orquesta sinfónica
no te pierdas esta oportunidad te
esperamos el jueves a las 4 de la tarde
en la escuela fulana de tal y segi a ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta el huapango de moncayo
tan hermoso después nos fuimos a las
secundarias y primarias de la zona ahí
les pedíamos a los maestros que nos
permitieran dar un aviso a sus alumnos
lo primero que les preguntábamos era
chicos a quién le gusta la música todos
levantaban sus manos invariablemente la
música es parte fundamental de nuestra
vida nos acompaña desde que estamos en
el vientre materno cuando escuchamos el
corazón de mamá ya nuestra vida tiene
ritmo y así nos acompaña en las buenas y
en las malas cuando nos enamoramos
vamos serenata cuando estamos en una
fiesta y bailamos cuando nos rompen el
corazón y escuchamos puras canciones
tristes cuando hacemos ejercicio cuando
estamos en el coche manejando en fin la
música es inherente a la vida del ser
humano pero lo interesante se ponía
cuando les preguntábamos a los niños
oigan a ver a quién le gustaría aprender
a tocar un instrumento oa cantar ahí la
respuesta nos la daba la chispa que
surgía en sus ojos
las miradas expectantes y con entre
ellos como con mucha complicidad
nunca faltó la niña o el niño que
preguntarán maestra cuánto cuestan las
clases cuando les decíamos que nada que
era un proyecto gratuito todas las manos
se levantaban en el aire como palomas
mensajeras nuestra tarea era descifrar
ese mensaje
y se llegó el jueves tan esperado 3 30
de la tarde todos nosotros ya listos en
la escuela con las fichas de registro
con la información necesaria cuatro de
la tarde se abren las puertas de la
escuela y van llegando algunos a
cuentagotas para las cuatro y media la
fila daba la vuelta a la manzana niños
niñas está arrastrando literalmente de
la mano de sus papás a sus mamás a la
abuelita al hermano a la tía para que
pidieran informes grupos de jóvenes que
llegaban juntos otros separados solitos
por ahí saben cuántos llegaron 356 niños
niñas y jóvenes que querían formar parte
de una orquesta era como si no hubieran
nada más que hacer en ese momento a esa
hora en esa comunidad o más bien diría
yo era como si no hubiera nada mejor que
hacer
quizá era mucho más divertido por lo
menos interesante saber qué iba a pasar
ahí en una orquesta en unas clases que
nos venían a ofrecer que estar en la
casa viendo la tele o pegado al facebook
en el celular o echando caguama en la
esquina
entonces ahí estábamos nosotros
les preguntábamos niños qué instrumento
les gustaría tocar batería guitarra uno
por ahí violín clarinete los
instrumentos que ellos conocían pero al
día siguiente llegamos con un grupo de
maestros maravillosos que interpretaron
para los chicos varias piezas
presentándoles los instrumentos que
forman parte de una orquesta sinfónica
completa ahí empezó la magia porque era
la primera vez en su vida que veían
todos los instrumentos que sonaban en
una orquesta sinfónica y nunca se me van
a olvidar muchos de los comentarios de
los niños como el 11 que hizo un chico
que decía yo quiero ese ese instrumento
y una niña le decía como por qué es que
se parece muchísimo a la voz de mi papá
que vive en eeuu y que yo no lo conozco
porque nada más hablo por teléfono él
está allá desde que yo nací
un fagot
un fagot es un instrumento enorme de la
familia de los alientos madera que suena
muy grave muy ronco seguramente como la
voz del papá de ese chico
llegó la semana siguiente ya las clases
empezaban en forma el lunes
un maestro encuentra a un petardo hecho
a mano en una de las mochilas de los
jóvenes un petardo hecho con cohetes que
es como una pequeña bomba que en
cualquier momento podría explotar
el maestro cauteloso cuidadoso se fue a
enterrar el petardo a un cerro en vez de
denunciar al joven lo enterró tan
cuidadosamente para que no le explotara
a nadie en la cara
y eso no fue lo mejor lo mejor fue lo
que pasó con el chavo el joven se dio
cuenta de que no lo estaban juzgando de
que le quitaron el petardo pero no le
quitaron la oportunidad de continuar en
un programa que sin duda cambiaría su
vida aunque él no lo sabía hoy ese chico
está a punto de entrar a una de las
mejores universidades del país a
estudiar música profesionalmente es ahí
cuando decimos que música para la vida
realmente está cambiando el mundo un
músico a la vez y así como esta historia
yo podría contarles muchísimas cuantas
como 1800 porque son más de 1800 niños
niñas y jóvenes que han pasado por este
proyecto desde 2013 cuando arrancamos
pues honestamente teníamos muchas
hipótesis que si la música sería capaz
de transformar verdaderamente a la
comunidad que si la música podría
ampliar sus perspectivas podría mejorar
su vida y hoy después de seis años
podemos platicar nuestra propia historia
no la de venezuela o la de colombia
de la ciudad de mexico la de san luís
potosí porque este es un proyecto 100 y
orgullosamente potosino en 6 años hemos
creado 4 orquestas sinfónicas 2 coros y
2 bandas en 8 municipios del estado son
más de 65 maestros profesionales
facilitadores comunitarios coordinadores
directores que todos los días van a dar
clases de música a una comunidad cabe
mencionar que algunos incluso cambian de
residencia o van y vienen como si fueran
a la zona industrial en un camión todos
los días porque porque los niños y
jóvenes acuden de lunes a viernes de 4 a
8 de la tarde es una orquesta de alto
rendimiento un grupo de alto rendimiento
imaginen ustedes todo lo que se previene
en un espacio de 4 horas todos los días
en comunidades con tantos factores de
riesgo
música para la vida transforma porque no
solamente se les enseña música a los
niños también les damos talleres cursos
de habilidades para la vida en donde
ellos aprenden y adquieren herramientas
que les permiten enfrentarse de mejor
manera a sus contextos sin duda la
música da algo que siento yo que no da
nada más enseña un lenguaje distinto los
niños adquieren una forma de expresar
que además comparten con muchas otras
personas en todo el mundo la música les
devuelve esas alas que alguna vez hace
mucho el contexto les arrebato
la universidad autónoma de san luis
potosí hizo un estudio de investigación
de impacto porque yo podría pasarme la
vida hablándoles de lo maravilloso que
hace este proyecto pero no es lo mismo
que una agencia externa lo diga y más
una universidad como la autónoma
entonces los resultados son que
efectivamente este proyecto tiene un
impacto positivo en la vida de los
participantes los chavos aumentan su
autoestima considerablemente aumentan su
permanencia escolar es decir esto ya es
una apuesta a largo plazo aumentan sus
aspiraciones ahí ya se remueven todas
las aguas estancadas ahí ya se llenan
los espacios vacíos y algo ocurre con
los padres y las madres ustedes tendrían
que hay un concierto y ver las caras de
felicidad y de orgullo de todos los
papás las mamás las abuelas los tíos los
primos cuando ven a su familia a su hijo
a su hija ahí en un escenario tocando un
instrumento y haciendo sonar algo
maravilloso
este proyecto no solo toca al niño toca
también a las familias y a las
comunidades por completo y a los que
estamos también detrás de él siempre les
decimos a los chavos que la orquesta es
como un símil de la sociedad así como en
la orquesta es indispensable entender
que todos los integrantes todos los
instrumentos son importantes e incluso
interdependientes de todos los demás así
también en la sociedad si nosotros
queremos que suene la sinfonía de la
cultura de paz de la justicia del amor
de la generosidad del respeto tenemos
que reconocer y recuperar el valor de
todos y reconocer que formamos parte
juntos de algo mucho más grande
muchas veces nos preguntan oye cómo le
han hecho porque este es un proyecto
exitoso en san luís potosí
la respuesta es muy simple sumando
voluntades este proyecto tiene el apoyo
de los tres órdenes de gobierno tiene el
apoyo también de personas y empresas
socialmente responsables es muy
importante la participación de la
iniciativa privada este no es un
proyecto ni sexenal ni tiene un color ni
un partido este es un proyecto de la
gente de todos y lo que intentamos es
acortar la brecha entre las distintas
realidades a los niños que tienen un
nombre y un apellido los acercamos a esa
gente que apuesta por ellos entonces se
conocen los ven tocar en el teatro de la
paz en el bicentenario en algún
escenario por acá e incluso la gente se
acerca de las comunidades que es lo más
rico para entender este proyecto vivir
el día a día de los chicos
es muy gratificante platicarles sobre
música para la vida porque sin duda este
proyecto va a dejar una huella la está
dejando ya como les comento son más de
1800 niños niñas y jóvenes para quienes
la música ya es parte indispensable de
su vida no queremos hacer músicos
profesionales aunque está ocurriendo hay
un porcentaje interesante de chavos que
al salir del sistema quieren estudiar
música de manera profesional pero la
idea es hacer gente más feliz que tengan
un poquito más de posibilidades y de
aspiraciones que se acerquen a la
realidad es que antes no imaginaron y
para terminar quisiera invitarlos a
reflexionar sobre qué nos motiva a
nosotros que nos hace felices si como
les comenté al principio como a mí les
hace felices el servicio a los demás
hagamos todos algo juntos porque este
mundo no va a cambiar solo con unos
cuantos tenemos que participar todos
juntos muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]